bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir
s'interroge sur les excès et les dérives
du Mitou en politique bonsoir
Marie-Christine Tabet et merci d'être là
vous publiez avec Christophe Dubois
sexus diabolique chez Albin Michel c'est
une enquête fouillée et courageux qui
nous invite avec nuance au
questionnements sur la revanche des
femmes à faire Abad katnas Bayou on en a
beaucoup parlé ici à l'assemblée des cas
sont très différents la libération de la
parole une victoire mais le changement
d'époque n'autorise pas tout on va y
revenir très longuement dans la deuxième
partie mais on commence ce soir avec la
chasse aux fraudeurs c'est l'actualité
politique du jour Gabriel Attal a
présenté son plan anti fraude social
pour faire des économies alors l'État
sera intraitable promethyl cotisation
sociale prestation maladie à l'occasion
quel est l'ampleur de l'afro dans notre
pays et ce plan est-il vraiment à la
hauteur grand débat dans un instant sur
ce plateau avec mes invités de retrouver
les parties pris de nos affranchis et
puis Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le
programme vous me suivez Marie Christine
tabbay ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est un vieux serpent de mer auquel
tous les gouvernements au premier de
s'attaquer la fraude sociale en France
estimée entre 6 et 8 milliards d'euros
par an par la Cour des comptes Gabriel
Attal l'ambitieux ministre des contes
publics peut-il réussir là où tous ces
prédécesseurs ont échoué bonsoir Didier
Martin bonsoir et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de Côte d'Or et
vous débattez ce soir avec Ségolène a
mis au bonsoir merci d'être là député la
France insoumise de Loire-Atlantique
bonsoir Véronique clouazy bonsoir
bienvenue député les républicains de
l'Orne enfin Frédéric bizard bienvenue
ravi de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
professeur d'économie loscp et président
de l'Institut de santé les
professionnels de santé sont pointés du
droit dans ce dossier médecin pharmacien
sur facturation prescription abusive Fos
arrêt maladie on va faire le tri dans
tout ça et on va en parler tout à
l'heure c'est d'ailleurs dans vos
colonnes du Parisien Marie-Christine que
Gabriel attaque a présenté ses annonce
ce matin vous enseigner des dipôles
n'hésitez pas à intervenir à interroger
nos invités vous le souhaitez alors à
quoi ressemble ce plan pour commencer il
a deux secondes Stéphane blackovski
c'est le chrono c'est parti
deux secondes le chrono de Blacko pour
voir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors la France sociale dans notre pays
alors ce soir on se branche sur un
problème qui est resté dans l'ombre
pendant des années et des années c'est
bien la preuve c'est pendant longtemps
on était même incapable d'estimer le
montant de cette fraude sociale vous
voyez il y a pourtant des enquêtes qui
avaient été lancées un rapport commandé
par Édouard Philippe en 2019 mais
chiffrage impossible disait les auteurs
du rapport donc les parlementaires s'ils
sont mis l'année suivante avec pas plus
de succès impossible d'obtenir un
chiffre fiable donc l'explication du
rapport consistait à dire écoutez dans
les organismes sociaux leur culture
d'entreprises en quelque sorte c'est de
verser des allocations il considère que
le contrôle c'est pas vraiment leur
boulot ah bah oui mais s'il y a pas de
contrôle comment oui parce que même la
Cour des comptes du coup en l'absence de
contrôle vous allez voir que dans son
rapport de 2020 170 pages sur le sujet
tout ça pour dire bah vu qu'on a pas de
chiffre on est incapable d'avoir une
estimation fiable bon ça a quand même un
peu changé aujourd'hui dans le dernier
rapport la Cour des comptes dit
attention non il faut quand même changer
l'échelle sur la lutte contre la fraude
sociale et surtout libre les estimations
6 à 8 milliards de fraudes sociales
chaque année et donc seulement un
milliard 6 recouverts selon les
estimations 2/3 ou 3/4 de la fraude
reste dans la poche des froideurs donc
forcément le ministre du Budget qui
s'appelle Gabriel dit que ça peut pas
durer il tape du point sur la table il
veut renforcer les contrôles donc ce
matin dans votre journal vous donner
quelques mesures il disait par exemple
on va faire
240 contrôle en plus à l'URSSAF donc ça
c'est plutôt pour les employeurs qui
paieraient pas leur cotisation mais
aussi elle assurance maladie 400
enquêteurs en 450 enquêteurs en plus
pour traquer les arrêts maladie bref il
y a une volonté d'ici 2027 de doubler
les résultats des contrôles sur la
fraude sociale en écoute
on a beaucoup progressé ces cinq
dernières années sous le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le montant
des redressements c'est-à-dire de la
fraude qu'on identifie a augmenté de
35%. c'est beaucoup moi je souhaite
qu'on aille encore plus loin et donc
dans ce pour quinquennat qui s'ouvre on
augmente de 100%. alors bon tout le
monde connaît le dicton qui vole un œuf
vole un bœuf sauf qu'en réalité pas
globalement on pense tous que voler un
petit œuf comme moins grave que de voler
un gros bœuf donc évidemment
il veut pas donner le sentiment de
poursuivre les petits fraudeurs en
laissant passer les gros fraudeurs entre
les mailles du filet donc par exemple
sur la question des prestations de santé
il dit attention c'est un domaine où si
on prend les montants de la fraude 70%
de ses montants ce sont des
professionnels de santé qui sont filous
et donc voilà décide de prendre des
mesures en disant on en a déjà prise
n'oubliez pas que les gros on les traque
aussi écouté
on a aussi l'an dernier je le dis
identifier une soixantaine de pharmacies
pour lesquelles il y avait eu des
facturations de tests antigénique à
l'assurance maladie qui ne correspondait
pas à des tests antigéniques qui avaient
été faits sur des patients pour un
montant de 58 millions d'euros c'est
près d'un million d'euros en moyenne par
pharmacie concernée mais bon vous avez
bien que Gabriel est fidèle à la fameuse
ligne mais en même temps énormément de
temps il y a aussi des mesures qui
étaient plutôt réclamés par la droite
voient même par l'extrême droite Gabriel
cherche à faire une carte vitale qui
soit infalsifiable c'était dans le
programme de Marine Le Pen en 2022 et en
2017 et là où ça se complique un peu
c'est qu'en fait ça se tire un peu dans
les pattes au gouvernement sur le sujet
parce que ce matin le ministère de
l'Intérieur a fait savoir à l'AFP un
petit coup de fil comme ça que
finalement techniquement cette carte
infalsifiable c'était pas possible ah
oui mais ça c'est Gabriel Attal en face
si on lui dit que techniquement c'est
pas possible il comprend pas on écoute
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui existe en
Belgique c'est ce qui existe au Portugal
c'est ce qui existe en Suède je veux
bien qu'on ait plein de problèmes en
France qu'on dise en permanence qui a
des choses qui sont impossibles c'est
possible en Belgique au Portugal en
Suède je sais pas vous moi j'ai entendu
Gérald Darmanin il est même pas foutu de
faire un truc que les belges font depuis
10 ans bon j'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu tendu en ce moment entre du
gouvernement et pendant ce temps-là
forcément au RN bah on boit du petit
lait sur cette question on écoute
si Marine Le Pen n'est pas mis la fraude
au centre de sa campagne lors de 2022 et
si on n'avait pas fait cette proposition
de loi et bien aujourd'hui le
gouvernement n'en parlerait pas donc
quelque part le gouvernement nous marque
à la culotte mais encore plus vite que
lui bon bah voilà personne j'imagine sur
ce plateau va défendre les fraudeurs
maintenant savoir quels sont les
fraudeurs à traquer en priorité
comment on fait pour les traquer ça je
pense que des bananer en prélimité merci
beaucoup Stéphane on va revenir dans le
détail sur les différents éléments de de
la fraude sociale dans notre pays mais
quand même politiquement c'est pas
neutre de s'attaquer à la fraude sociale
c'est vraiment la proposition que fait
depuis la nuit détendre rassemblement
national c'est pour leur répondre que
que vous ouvrez ce dossier là
aujourd'hui
fraude sociale fraude fiscal c'est la
même chose c'est de l'argent public
c'est de l'argent de la solidarité qui
doit être redirigé vers ceux qui en ont
besoin donc c'est par sortir un serpent
de mer c'est pas faire la chasse aux
fraudeur c'est lutter contre les fraudes
pour avoir quand même l'équivalence qui
concerne les prestations les allocations
l'équivalent récupérer l'équivalent du
budget du ministère de l'Intérieur en
même temps on se rend compte sur ce
dossier parce qu'il y a un problème
d'efficacité 6 à 8 milliards d'euros par
an c'est le montant de la fraude sociale
c'est la Cour des comptes qu'il a estimé
et Gabriel Attal veut ramener 3
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin du
quinquennat donc ça veut dire que sur le
plan des résultats c'est pas évident d'y
arriver faut déjà fixerrables
on veut qu'il soit le ministre a exprimé
sur la fraude on est passé de 35% de
recouvrement de redressement il 100% et
pour ça il met des postes 1000 nouveaux
postes créés qui dans différentes
branches correspondantes URSSAF la
maladie etc mais il ne vous postes pour
effectivement arriver à récupérer cet
argent qui est soit mal dû mal versé qui
est parfois indu et qui doit aller vers
la justice sociale alors Ségolène ce qui
est intéressant c'est que pour le
l'entendre à l'entendre le ministre il
veut pas stigmatiser le très gros de la
fraude c'est la fraude au cotisations
sociales ce sont les entreprises ce sont
les employeurs c'est le travail au noir
on va dire franchement et clairement en
tout cas et en tout cas il présente
aussi
les professionnels ça ça devrait à la
France insoumise vous parlez il y a pas
évidemment de volonté de pointer qui que
ce soit là évidemment ça nous parle pour
autant ce qu'on sait de la fraude
aujourd'hui et je vais reprendre les
arguments de Monsieur Martin qui sont
parfaits à savoir qu'effectivement la
fraude sociale la fraude fiscale c'est
la même chose c'est que c'est de
l'argent qui devrait revenir aux
collectifs et qu'il n'arrive pas
objectifs ou qui est mal redistribué et
aujourd'hui on sait que 80 milliards à
100 milliards donc 10 à 12 fois plus que
la fraude sociale c'est la fraude
fiscale la
productions de Monsieur Martin qui sont
bons il faut mettre les moyens et quand
on sait que justement les moyens pour
lutter contre la fraude fiscale ont été
les moyens humains ont été réduits d'un
tiers pour pour lutter contre la fraude
des moyens pour la fraude fiscale ça
c'était égal 15 jours on a eu des bails
insoumise sur la fraude sociale bien sûr
oui bien sûr parce que l'idée c'est pas
tant de enfin l'idée c'est pas de
chasser le petit fraudeur et de pas
partir à la chasse aux pauvres l'idée
c'est effectivement d'avoir un système
juste sur lequel les il y a pas personne
se fasse d'argent indu pour que
effectivement on s'appuie se profiter à
tous et à toutes mais donc effectivement
de s'attaquer aux employeurs qui ne
déclarent pas peut s'attaquer
effectivement ou surfacture mais je
pense encore une fois que on regarde les
choses par le mauvais trou de la
lorgnette on a d'un côté une petite voix
d'eau et de l'autre côté on prend on
prend la mer à grandes eaux donc il faut
bien
social mais encore une fois il y a déjà
eu des annonces on va faire le débat sur
la santé en tout cas non mais entre les
annonces et la réalité c'est ça aussi
Véronique clovagy mais à regarder de
près la fraude sociale elle plaide pour
le projet de loi immigration Gérald
Darmanin parce que les employeurs le
Medef en tête le disent laissez-nous
embaucher dans le bâtiment laissez-nous
déclarer au fond les étrangers qui
travaillent déjà dans la restauration
alors il faut le faire alors on lutter
contre la fraude sociale je ne voudrais
pas faire un lien je dirais entre la
fraude sociale et l'immigration d'une
manière générale je crois qu'il faut
lutter contre toutes les fraudes cela
participe à la fois au maintien du
contrat social et au pacte républicain
mais les étrangers en situation
régulière qui travaillent dans la
vibrations ils existent aujourd'hui et
il faudrait peut-être qu'ils aient un
contrat pour que justement tout le monde
puisse clairement payer déclarer les
cotisations mais vous savez que vous
avez aujourd'hui la possibilité pour les
entreprises de déclarer de payer des
cotisations pour une personne en
situation irrégulière c'est je dirais un
contre-sens parce que par définition
nous pourrions penser qu'il n'est pas
possible de déclarer une personne en
situation irrégulière hors c'est
possible il suffit d'obtenir un numéro
auprès de la Sécurité sociale et c'est
tout à fait possible les cotisations
peuvent être payées voilà donc cela
existe vous validez la présentation des
choses c'est-à-dire que le gros des
fraudeurs c'est plutôt les
professionnels que les ménages où on va
le dire simplement les gens les plus
modestes je crois qu'il ne faut pas
cristalliser sur une ou l'autre
catégorie il faut lutter contre toute
les fraudes ça ça me va cela me paraît
important après il y a des montants
différents voilà je crois que le
gouvernement peut à l'air du numérique a
l'air de automatisation comme on peut le
vivre à l'air d'une numérisation qui va
s'accélérer avec l'intelligence
artificielle le gouvernement a la
possibilité de faire un certain nombre
de recoupements je pense par exemple
pour la fraude aux prestations sociales
parce que cela existe le gouvernement
peut faire exécutif peut faire des
recoupements entre la branche famille
dans les sécurités sociales et la
direction générale des finances
publiques de la même manière pour le
versement des retraites qui peuvent
exister aujourd'hui sur des comptes qui
ne sont pas forcément en France la
branche vieillesse peut faire des
recoupements
politiques pour vous on a des moyens
nouveaux et puis il faut trouver de
l'argent on le sait la dette est
colossale donc il faut y aller ah oui
oui je crois vous pourriez voter un
ensemble de mesures aux républicains je
voudrais simplement rappeler que nous
avions à l'initiative des républicains
demandaient une commission d'enquête qui
était présidé par Patrick Hetzel qui a
rendu ses conclusions en septembre 2020
sur la situation de la lutte contre les
fraudes sociales où nous avons fait un
certain nombre de propositions notamment
à travers la carte Vitale biométrique la
lutte contre je dirais les assurés
fantômes
entre les républicains la majorité
puisqu'on sait que vous jouez les
arbitres très régulièrement dans les
jours que l'on peut regretter nous avons
l'impression finalement que le
gouvernement ouvre des contre-feux pour
oublier cette malheureuse séquence cette
séquence de crispation de la société
avec le projet de loi retraite et nous
voyons d'ailleurs au niveau du couac qui
peut exister entre le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre en charge des
comptes publics sur la carte Vitale avec
la carte nationale d'identité donc bon
on voit bien que c'est un contrefeu qui
est ouvert alors justement Frédéric
bizarre on va venir dans le détail on a
un sujet sur ça sur les questions de
fraude en matière de santé mais
l'annonce dans tout le monde parle cette
fameuse fusion entre la carte d'identité
et la carte Vitale on sait que c'est
très difficile d'obtenir une
renouvellement des papiers d'identité
donc on imagine même pas le temps qu'il
faudrait pour renouveler fusionner
l'ensemble des citoyens français c'est
un effet d'annonce et démagogique pour
vous
alors ce qui me surprend toujours c'est
que un ministre parle d'un outil je
pense que ce qu'on manque c'est une
stratégie une stratégie cohérente année
après année vous voyez que si bien un
thème qui devrait rassembler l'ensemble
des partis politiques c'est bien la
lutte contre la fraude je pense pas il y
a aucun parti politique qui sont
qui sont satisfaits bon je rappelle
juste aussi que 8 milliards prenons la
tranche haute de de fraude sociale c'est
0,1% de nos dépenses sociales ne
laissons pas penser que les dépenses
sociales sont un panier percé ou chacun
se sert et tout ça et bon c'est quand
même assez impressionnant si c'est pas
sous-estimé de voir que finalement 99,9%
les prestations sociales sont justement
délivrer d'ailleurs on voit bien que la
fraude sociale est vraiment la partie
émergée de l'iceberg la partie immergée
de l'iceberg c'est l'efficacité de notre
modèle social qu'il a devrait faire à
mon avis en tout cas le sujet d'un débat
intense amélioré notre système de santé
dans une enveloppe constante mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'améliorer
notre système de retraite
donc
le ministre parle de d'une idée qui est
d'abord qui qui sous-tend un principe
qu'on doit essayer d'atteindre qui est
en effet de pouvoir croiser l'identité
enfin de même de fondre l'identité
civile l'identité qui je suis l'identité
sociale ce que je perce perçoit et
l'identité fiscale ce que je dois
déclarer sur le principe déjà bien sûr
qu'il faut arriver à le faire et si on
n'y arrive pas c'est pas qu'il y a un
manque je pense en tout cas de volonté
politique c'est qu'on a un vrai problème
de complexité des modèles que l'on est
en train de simplifier année après année
mais on y va quand même très doucement
on voit la difficulté avec le système de
retraite de créer un vrai système
universel sur lequel tout le monde est à
peu près d'accord mais on voit que c'est
compliqué politiquement d'y aller donc
juste pour finir c'est qu'il y a par
contre une faille c'est le manque
d'investissement on parlait de moyens
tout à l'heure mais c'est pas que des
moyens humains vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
on contrôle à peu près 3% des
prestations social on peut doubler les
moyens humains et en contre les 6%
du numérique et de l'intelligence
artificielle or ce que je regrette c'est
que le ministère encore une fois c'est
pas une question politique mais Bercy il
est pas très cohérent merci dit il y a
un an il faut qu'on lance une commission
IGAS IGF et qu'on fait un truc bon la
commission rend son rapport sur le le
biométrique la carte biométrique est dit
oh mais en fait ça coûte trop cher un
milliard bon ben donc si on veut pas
investir dans les outils qui permettent
vraiment de faire la différence même
s'il peut y avoir des soucis avec la
CNIL mais tout ça peut se régler donc il
faut un vrai investissement dans les
nouvelles technologies un investissement
humain aussi des syndicats le répètent
mais il faut investir si on veut des
résultats c'est vrai que c'est l'annonce
dont tout le monde parle parce que là ça
aurait des résultats très rapidement si
on avait une seule chose très concrète
par exemple la carte Vitale il y a
encore 30% des cartes vitales ou la
photographie ne figure pas c'est quand
même envoyé un simple de vérifier que le
porteur de la carte est bien l'assuré ou
l'ayant droit il faut absolument nous
avons encore beaucoup de gens dans la
part de fraude à la carte vitale qui
prête leur carte notamment exactement
donc ce simple moyen c'est c'est
élémentaire mettre la photographie sur
la carte Vitale c'est intéressant on a
désactivé 2 millions 300000 cartes
vicaires vitales qui étaient soit
périmées soit à certaines etc sur les
centres de santé par exemple le fait que
l'assuré social après des soins
dentaires après des soins
ophtalmologiques puissent recevoir
lui-même sur ce sur son téléphone on
parle de moyen numérique la facture des
soins dont il a bénéficié il va lui-même
pouvoir contrôler s'il y a
surfacturation ou pas c'est les moyens
très simple oui mais là les centres de
santé si vous voulez parce qu'on a
laissé le lourd rentrer dans la bergerie
quand même parce que si vous voulez là
où il y a un problème de régulation
c'est qu'on a un système qui se
financiarise de plus en plus avec des
fonds d'investissement qui rentrent dans
les de santé les centres dentaires les
centres d'ophtalmologie c'est pas les
médecins les professionnels de santé
libéraux historiques qui voulaient qui
étaient certes sur un modèle libéral
mais qui était sur un modèle individuel
simplement qui recherchait une
rémunération là on est sur des fonds
d'investissement qui sont souvent très
loin dans les centres de décision de la
France et qui n'ont qu'un seul objectif
c'est comme ça qui fonctionne le
maximiser leur profit selon les règles
et économique des marchés financiers
donc si vous voulez la sécurité sociale
elle est pas vraiment faite pour
répondre à cet objectif de maximisation
des profils vous avez la surfacturation
c'est une fraude mais bon
comment est-ce qu'on peut maximiser le
chiffre la surfacturation nous avons
l'exemple de 502 santé qui ont été
déconventionnés
de quoi on parle médecin pharmacien
infirmier qui sont ces professionnels de
santé qui fraudent comment on peut
frauder c'est pas comme du doigt mode
d'emploi mais c'était un tour d'horizon
qui vous est présenté par Hélène
Bonduelle Frédéric prabono et lindao des
équipes de France Télévisions regardez
il suffit de taper arrêt de travail sur
ce réseau social et moyennant quelques
euros et quelques minutes un internaute
peut obtenir un arrêt de travail
un document falsifié mais avec un vrai
nom de médecin qui lui n'a jamais vu de
patient ce généraliste en a fait les
frais j'ai reçu plusieurs appels des
employeurs de mutuelle de plusieurs
sécurités sociales demandant de
confirmer les arrêts de travail devant
la présence de beaucoup de
d'incohérences je suis tombé assez dénue
parce que je me suis rendu compte qu'une
personne s'était permise de faire des
faux arrêts de travail avec mon nom et
ce dans toute la France donc vous avez
le vrai numéro d'immatriculation de de
la personne son vrai nom les dates
d'arrêt par contre vous pouvez voir donc
il y a mon nom mon adresse avec une
signature qui n'est pas la mienne des
fraudes qui ont coûté
3,4 millions d'euros à la sécurité
sociale en 2021
450 cyber enquêteurs seront déployés
pour lutter contre ces faux certificats
et pour traquer aussi les arrêts dit de
complaisance des plateformes de
téléconsultation comme celle-ci peuvent
en délivrer à la demande mais également
des médecins peu scrupuleux cela aurait
coûté plus de 30 millions d'euros à
l'État au précédent quinquennat quand on
voit ces plateformes commerciales
puisque c'est bien de plateforme
commerciale qui proposent
de faire venir à eux des médecins
mercenaires pour pouvoir faire des
téléconsultations et souvent à l'issue
de cette consultation d'un arrêt maladie
tant que les téléconsultation seront
autorisées pour des patients dont vous
n'êtes pas le médecin traitant ou qui ne
vous ont jamais consulté ça va être open
bar pour certains et encore une fois je
te l'opprobre sur toute une profession
ses proprement insupportables dans le
collimateur de l'Assurance Maladie
également ces centres de santé dentaire
ophtalmo qui pratique régulièrement des
surfacturations c'est le même acte en
fait qui a été voilà payé deux fois par
exemple un patient se rend pour un acte
assez courant comme un détartrage et au
final le centre facture un nombre
conséquent d'actes et notamment des
actes onéreux tels des prothèses
dentaires en cas de fraude avérées
du bon sens de lutter contre ces fraudes
de santé à l'assurance maladie la gauche
partenaire sur ce sujet là évidemment on
peut pas laisser passer ce genre de
pratique frauduleuse alors ça c'est une
évidence ça me paraît ça me paraît clair
pour autant je pense que la méthode
employée pour le moment et ce qui est
annoncé ne va pas forcément répondre aux
besoins déjà parce que la mise en œuvre
j'attends vraiment de comprendre comment
la mise en oeuvre par exemple de la
fusion dont on parlait de la carte
d'identité pour demain ni après-demain
de temps voire d'années aujourd'hui il
faut il faut plusieurs mois pour arriver
à se faire renouveler sa carte
d'identité donc comment est-ce qu'on va
faire combien ça va coûter aussi ça non
plus on nous le dit pas combien combien
de milliards on va devoir investir juste
pour ces bouts de plastique avec une
puce dessus alors qu'on nous dit que il
faut aller récupérer quelques milliards
à droite et à gauche et pour vous c'est
faux arrêts maladie ces centres de santé
qui surfacture c'est évident ça fait
partie voilà d'un problème auquel il
faut répondre c'est effectivement un
problème sur lequel il faut qu'on
s'attaque d'ailleurs c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles
nous n'avons jamais été pour la
téléconsultation je pense que ici on en
a déjà beaucoup débattu ces derniers
mois justement sur les l'accès aux soins
et ça a été une vraie question de dire
effectivement aujourd'hui quand on a
plus de médecins pour beaucoup de gens
la téléconsultation ou un équivalent
c'est une abus possible mais pour autant
effectivement beaucoup d'appuis surtout
beaucoup d'erreurs médicales etc donc il
y a aussi il y a tout il y a est un
volet autour de la téléconsultation mais
effectivement les abus ils sont
possibles et donc ça pose effectivement
cette question de comment comment est-ce
qu'on lutte et je pense que le fait de
s'attaquer d'abord aux professionnels
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont la possibilité
technique de de le faire j'aime bien moi
l'idée de du collègue du collègue Martin
sur le fait que éventuellement on
reçoivent on reçoit la facture en tant
que en tant que assuré de recevoir le
détail de ce qu'on a eu après il y a des
fois penser à un accouchement par
exemple recevoir la facture d'un
accouchement vous avez des dizaines
voire des centaines de de lignes sur sur
la facture aller faire le tri là dedans
de savoir qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a
été fait qu'est-ce qui a pas été fait
dans quel état j'étais au moment où on a
fait le soin est-ce que je suis capable
de me souvenir que effectivement il y a
eu voilà on est à la fois dans un sujet
de fond mais il y a beaucoup de
politiques parce que voilà et c'est la
question d'exemplarité c'est la question
de la confiance dans l'état social did
ça ça avec toutes les opportunités
technologiques du moment l'intelligence
artificielle etc vous pensez que on peut
arriver à des résultats vraiment je
crois que il faut continuer d'avoir
confiance dans notre vie
sociale
des astuces qui sont toujours mises en
œuvre sur l'arrêt de travail de
complaisance il serait intéressant de
savoir quels sont les arrêts de travail
secs et quels sont les arrêts de travail
qui sont accompagnés d'une prescription
la téléconsultation ça peut être une
très bonne chose en désert médical mais
il pourrait y avoir une dérive sur cet
arrêt de travail sec c'est tout à fait
il acceptable à mon avis alors sur les
surfacturations moi je n'ai parlé que de
l'optique et que les soins dentaires
encore une fois je reviens sur le modèle
l'évolution du modèle de santé depuis 20
ans a largement favorisé le
développement des fraudes juste sur le
plan du modèle économique pourquoi parce
que quand vous avez ces nouveaux centres
qui ouvrent qui ont des objectifs
commerciaux le matin avec des centres
qui se disent associatifs mais qui ont
des holdines financières à l'étranger ce
cheval je veux pas avoir l'air de mais
c'est quand même le modèle qu'on a
laissé se développer pourquoi parce
qu'on a pensé de ces centres de santé
historiquement les centres de santé ont
une vocation sociale et en fait on
permis de compléter un petit peu
l'organisation assez libérale du système
donc les centres de santé ces groupes là
ont repris un peu l'appellation centre
de santé et on dit nous on va faire du
social sauf qu'il faut évidemment
l'inverse du social et ça on a quand
même un petit peu du mal à en sortir le
médecin a très bien parlé des
plateformes de téléconsultation c'est le
même modèle il faut c'est médecin ne
voient aucun patient juste par
l'intermédiaire du numérique et ont
comme instruction de leurs employeurs
puis salariés de maximiser les les
consultations bon c'est étonnant qu'il y
ait des consultations un peu fantômes
non c'est pas très étonnant donc les la
régulation des systèmes si on veut un
système solaire parce que on peut
laisser des grands groupes à ce
moment-là intégrer le modèle et dire
c'est privé c'est ceux qui peuvent avoir
une assurance privée dédiée à ce
financement là à l'anglaise mais c'est
pas notre modèle la deuxième chose c'est
quand même je veux bien qu'on utilise la
méthode Coué mais ça fait 20 ans qu'on
essaie de développer le dossier médical
personnel on a quand même un boulet dans
la numérisation de notre de nos données
de santé comme d'ailleurs dans la
numérisation des des systèmes sociaux
l'État a échoué depuis 20 ans donc il
faut peut-être regarder différemment moi
je veux bien que l'État insiste en
disant on va y arriver on va y arriver
attendez un petit peu ça fait quand même
un numérisation les choses les choses
évoluent quand même pour le coup vous
allez vous allez à l'étranger regardez
votre regardez votre carte Vitale vous
pour en faire quoi de votre carte Vitale
aller sur le site Ameli on a
l'impression d'un site d'y à 20 ans
dernier point la vigie plus efficace
pour lutter contre la fraude c'est
l'assurer je rappelle que le modèle de
45 c'est une sécurité sociale qui est
gérée par l'assuré pour l'assurer avec
l'assuré l'État a repris tout le
contrôle dessus en disant c'est moi
manifestement ça marche pas très bien
jusqu'en vous dites l'État a échoué sans
doute mais bien aidé aussi par des
syndicats corporatifs de médecins qui
ont pas aidé forcément toujours à
numériser
quand même
mais vous avez raison je dis toujours
que la responsabilité collective et les
collègues
ce débat par le dernier volet parce
qu'il y a aussi de la fraude aux
allocations
aux prestations aux allocations sociales
RSA allocations parents isolés on a
découvert les retraités centenaires
alors très peu mais qui n'était pas les
réels bénéficiaires c'est le cas d'une
mission en Algérie de la de la retraite
ou du minimum retraite la véronique
louvagie dans la pure politique ou pas
parce que le gouvernement va mettre en
place la solidarité à la source et donc
tous ceux qui n'ont pas recours à ces
prestations vont pouvoir les percevoir
c'est le non recours ça ça va être réglé
donc en fait ce qui va rentrer dans les
caisses avec la chasse aux prestations
sociales indues va ressortir avec la
solidarité à la source ça c'est juste
c'est bien je pense que nous évoquiez
deux problèmes de problèmes là la
question de la fraude et la question
tu ne coïncidence il faut lutter contre
la faune fraude et il faut faire
effectivement en sorte que toutes les
personnes qui ont droit à certaines
prestations et qui en ont besoin
puissent y avoir recours parce que en
plus le plus souvent ce sont ces
personnes qui sont les plus en
difficulté par rapport à un système qui
n'ont pas les moyens ou non pas je
dirais les bonnes portes pour pouvoir
avoir accès donc oui il faut faire en
sorte que personne puisse y avoir accès
mais en ce qui concerne la fraude je
voudrais revenir sur le fait que
l'État les différentes caisses les
différents organismes
disposent de tas de données et il faut
autoriser je dirais le croisement des
fichiers et là effectivement il faut
nous parlons beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle depuis quelques mois et je
pense à ces centres de santé qui ou il
est possible de lister par centre de
santé je dirais toutes les prestations
qui sont facturées et voir si le ratio
des notes par rapport à un ensemble à
plus de vigilance et de surveillance
faut donner à la au CPAM la possibilité
de faire des croisements et de détecter
par requête le mot le mot de la fin
Didier Martin il y a quand même un
élément qui n'a absolument rien à voir
avec la lutte contre la fraude c'est
l'AE dans ce dans ce plan aujourd'hui
l'aide médicale d'État ceux qui en
bénéficié des étrangers en France en
situation régulière c'était 5 mois ça a
passé à 9 mois alors là pur politique
politicienne non c'est une mesure
importante aussi dont on doit débattre
moi ce que je voudrais dire en
conclusion c'est que la lutte contre la
fraude aux allocations sociales
permettra de financer le non recours
donc que tous ceux qui en ont besoin
puissent avoir accès à ces prestations
ça va faire l'objet d'un projet de loi à
venir on va s'arrêter là merci beaucoup
les choses ont été dites on sent que
voilà des points d'accord y compris
entre la gauche le centre droit centre
gauche et à droite sont possibles merci
à vous vous restez avec moi
Marie-Christine Tabet dans une dizaine
de minutes elle est partie pris de nos
affranchis ce soir l'économie avec Fanny
guinochet qui va revenir sur l'Airbus
des batteries électriques la gigafactory
franco-allemande inaugurée en grande
pompe aujourd'hui la politique j'aurais
mis Baudot quand le parti de Marine Le
Pen est obligé de faire une sorte de
reset de son programme présidentiel et
puis Bourbon Express ce soir retraite la
pression monte sur des épaules de
yellebrun Pivet pour que ce sur
l'abrogation des 64 ans n'est pas lieu
le 8 juin prochain mais d'abord on se
plonge dans sexus diabolikus chez Albin
Michel votre coteur Christophe Dubois
d'ailleurs va nous rejoindre dans un
tout petit instant vous êtes livré je le
disais à une enquête fouillée nuancée
sur le MiTo en politique la vague a
déferlé un peu plus tard dans notre
monde de l'Assemblée nationale et des
élus que dans d'autres pans de la
société pourquoi on voit ça dans le dans
l'invitation des miliciens serpinos et
puis on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Marie-Christine Tabbé
et Christophe Dubois c'est pour votre
enquête éclairante sur les conséquences
de la vague me to sur la vie politique
dans sexus diabolikus vous faites le
récit de toutes ces affaires harcèlement
violence sexuelle qui ont défrayé la
chronique politique ces dernières années
de Nicolas Hulot Adrien cattenin DSK
Denis Baupin Damien bad en passant par
Julien Bayou Christophe Dubois sexus
diabolikus c'est un peu la suite de
Sextus politicus qui avait à l'époque
brisé le tabou du sexe et de la
politique
Christophe Dubois Marie-Christine Tabbé
vous êtes journaliste passé par les
rédactions du Parisien de sept à Huit ou
encore du Journal du Dimanche ensemble
vous aviez déjà exploré les coulisses de
la SNCF les liens passionnés entre
l'Algérie et la France ou encore le
rapport des politiques avec l'argent
vous racontez que la révolution des
femmes a bouleversé la vie politique que
désormais la parole de celle-ci est
érigée en principe absolu que les hommes
politiques se doivent être exemplaires
ces féministes nouvelles générations se
sont Caroline de Haas Alice Coffin
on est dans la rue vous les féministe
pour institut ce rapport de force et
puis on le sera tant qu'il ne plaira pas
ou encore Sandrine Rousseau leur arme le
hashtag leur terrain de jeu les plateaux
télé au risque parfois d'ériger des
tribunaux médiatiques une poignée de
militantes derrière un téléphone
portable est aujourd'hui plus puissante
qu'une organisation politique elles
peuvent en 286 signé l'arène mort d'un
homme politique comme ce jour où les
lieux écologistes lance une bombe sur le
plateau de c'est à vous des accusations
de violences commises par Julien Bayou
sur son ex-compagne je pense qu'il y a
des comportements qui en effet sont de
nature à briser le la santé morale des
femmes Julien bayot qui devra renoncer
peut-être à ses fonctions au sein de
votre partie mais on verra cette by step
dans ce livre vous soulignez les
avancées de cette révolution féministe
mais en montrer également certaines
dérives qui inquiètent les politiques
chassent aux sorcières police des mœurs
des nations anonymes alors dites nous
depuis la vague me too assiste-t-on à
une nouvelle guerre des sexes
et bonsoir Christophe Dubois pour
pouvoir rejoindre sur ce plateau donc
vous êtes le coeur avec Marc Christine
tablet de ce Sextus diabolikus bah pour
répondre à cette question est-ce que
cette guerre des sexes c'est un peu le
piège dans lequel pourrait tomber ce
combat si ça lutteur de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes et
toutes les formes de sexisme notamment
dans la politique ce qui est sûr c'est
que le sexe est devenu est devenu une
arme déstabilisation politique lorsqu'on
a écrit sexuces politicus il y a une
quinzaine d'années sexe et politique
faisait bon ménage ont aujourd'hui que
les paramètres ont changé que le
logiciel est plus du tout de même le
mouvement me too en 2017 est passé par
là et les frontières qui étaient assez
claires entre ce qui est judiciaire et
ce qui n'est pas on était complètement
explosé par par cette révolution alors
c'est pas du tout un livre contre le
mouvement MiTo loin de là au contraire
vous y revenez longuement à travers les
différentes affaires dans lequel vous
avez beaucoup de révélations mais quand
même cette question de la guerre des
sexes elle est importante parce qu'on a
l'impression quand même que en politique
maintenant les hommes ils ont un peu la
trouille
sous couvert d'anonymat il pétoche quand
même non de cette déferlante là oui oui
déjà on en est rencontré beaucoup avec
les femmes on a eu aucun problème à
mettre leur nom elles étaient au
contraire alors revanche on a mis un
point d'interrogation enfin en tout cas
elles sont combattantes sur le sujet
alors que les hommes politiques on a
rencontré des accusés également mais ils
nous ont dit on va vous expliquer le
contexte mais on veut surtout pas
apparaître dans le livre en tout cas on
veut pas ce qu'on sache qu'on est ça
nous a permis de comprendre un peu où
ils étaient c'est-à-dire totalement
dépassé par le sujet pour la plupart ne
comprenant même pas ce qu'il leur arrive
mais en tout cas ils ont peur de
s'exprimer alors que je crois que dans
cette future idéologique et
d'identité d'ailleurs et de générations
politiques le tsunami est pris un peu
plus de temps à défaire les sur ce monde
là
[Musique]
secret enfin exactement de sortie de
crise va être signée par l'entremise de
l'avocat Jean-Pierre Mignard alors ce
qui est très intéressant dans ce livre
c'est que vous avez rencontré ces fameux
collectifs féministes ou néo-féministe
ça dépend comment on les regarde piloter
par des noms qu'on connaît Caroline de
Haas Alice Coffin Fatima Benomar comment
il fonctionne exactement ils sont si
puissants que ça ces collectif
aujourd'hui alors ils sont effectivement
très puissants mais ce qui est
intéressant vous avez montré
effectivement les figures emblématiques
c'est presque la génération
d'avant j'allais dire à l'oral sont
encore très influentes elles ont une
sorte de d'autorité morale sur ces
jeunes mais mais en fait les collectifs
ce qu'on voit sur la toile ceux qui ont
quand même une force assez puissante ce
sont des femmes très des filles très
jeunes
beaucoup plus radical que leurs aînés et
venu à la politique ou venue à l'action
uniquement pour la cause des femmes est
très très en guerre en fait elle se
disent en guerre en guerre ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que toute révolution à
ses excès et tant pis il y a pas
d'omelette sans casser des œufs si un
innocent est accusé à tort c'est pas si
grave au vu de la révolution en cours
pour elle c'est pas si grave au vu des
milands qui ont elles estiment que leurs
paroles n'a pas été entendue et le dégât
collatéral quelque part est assumé on
voit bien les dangers de
cette philosophie c'est vrai que Twitter
est devenu une arme de destruction
massive mais néanmoins ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que aujourd'hui ce
sont ces collectifs qui font bouger les
lignes pour vous malgré les dérives on
voit que la justice qui sur ces sujets
là sur ce sujet des violences sexistes
et sexuelles à est à la peine a du mal à
juger tout simplement des violeurs
présumés on voit bien qu'elle essaie de
de courir après ce mouvement et sans
être trop technique la jurisprudence de
l'appareil judiciaire évolué puisqu'on a
aujourd'hui une catégorie d'hommes on
les appelle les condamnés au soupçons
dire des hommes pour lesquels les faits
sont prescrits en résumé mais la justice
parce qu'il y a une sacralisation de la
victime considère que l'effet sont
établis donc on est dans un tronc dans
un entre deux qui est assez
inconfortable c'est bon bien sûr Nicolas
Hulot pour ne pas de figure là
c'est vrai ce que ce que vous dites
c'est c'est tout à fait ça c'est-à-dire
elle considère vraiment il faut bien
voir que dans ces collectifs elles ont
des mantras c'est à dire elle compte les
féminicides quasiment bon voilà c'est
sur leur site elle compte elle regarde
aussi le nombre de plats et c'est vrai
que la justice est quand même totalement
à la ramasse c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 0,6%
quand même des auteurs de viol en tout
cas qui sont pour qui sont condamnés et
14% qui sont poursuivis et donc ces
femmes là elles ces jeunes femmes là et
bien oui elle considère que même s'il
une petite erreur certaines nous l'ont
dit bah c'est pas grave les hommes sont
otages de l'histoire alors on va rentrer
dans les détails
le cas Julien Bayou forcément on a vu
d'ailleurs commencer collectif sur
Twitter était même à l'origine de la
question qui a posé sur le plateau de
c'est à vous la journée
alors c'est la député Sandrine Rousseau
qui ont entendu balance le nom de Julien
Bayou elle sait exactement ce qu'elle
fait à ce moment là
elle mesure la portée de ce qu'elle dit
à ce moment-là je pense qu'elle n'a pas
forcément mesurée le tsunami médiatique
au politique lorsqu'on l'a rencontré
elle avait l'air même sincèrement encore
choquée par les réactions que ça a
suscité même dans la rue elle s'est
sentie physiquement en danger après
force et de constater que c'est une
exécution médiatique politique sur la
base de témoignages anonymes et sur la
base d'un
fait de violence psychologique qui est
quelque chose de très ténu on est dans
des histoires de couple qui tournent mal
avec le sentiment qui est à l'origine
finalement d'une plainte qui ne savent
jamais été déposée il faut le rappeler
mais avec des accusations relayées
à tenter de mettre fin à ses jours et
vous intitulé ce chapitre là très chers
connard un clin d'oeil à Virginie
Despentes évidemment ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la violence
psychologique mal aimée au point de
vouloir mettre fin à ses jours ça
pourrait devenir un jour un délit alors
ce qui est dans le côté là la violence
psychologique mais c'est ce qui a essayé
de pousser Sandrine Rousseau mais rien
n'a été prouvé ni même déposé comme
plainte oui non déjà tout à l'heure pour
revenir sur Sandrine Rousseau elle elle
téléphone quand même avant de rentrer
sur le plateau comme effectivement sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
des menaces de plus en plus fortes
concernant Julien Bayou il faut voir que
Sandrine Rousseau elle appelle quand
même avant de rentrer sur le plateau
l'accompagne l'ex-compagne de Julien
Bayou pour lui demander est-ce que je
peux parler et effectivement la compagne
dit oui finalement vas-y et ce qui est
ce qui est aussi intéressant sur chez
Julien Bayou c'est que c'est un homme de
c'est devenu un homme de pouvoir dans
son patrie parti à ce moment là qu'il
est patron il est secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et on
l'appelle sur connard parce que pour
revenir sur le livre de Virginie
Despentes il collectionne les aventures
dans son parti il est sur un ancien
modèle en fait un peu dans le modèle
d'un don Juan de la politique et ça
aujourd'hui surtout dans des parties
féministes ça passe plus ça va plus et
peut-être heureusement chacun jugera les
réseaux sociaux alors évidemment c'est
ça qui change tout à la fois dans la
lutte et dans son efficacité mais aussi
pour le pire c'est ça Twitter en
particulier
on voit bien le problème que peut poser
des dons des dénonciations anonymes
relayées massivement qui peut qui
peuvent donner l'impression d'une vérité
mais une
information je mets des guillemets
relayée 10 ou 20 000 fois n'est pas
forcément la preuve d'une
longueur
que forcément une insulte sexiste ça n'a
rien à voir avec
une agression sexuelle un viol et
parfois ces réseaux ont tendance à tout
mettre sur le même plan oui on a
rencontré par exemple
Eric Brion qui est à l'ancien patron
d'une chaîne sportive qui est en fait le
premier me too français le balance ton
port alors en fait aujourd'hui encore
aujourd'hui il est croisé dans la rue
par des gens qui pensent qu'il a violé
la personne qui l'a dénoncé alors en
fait en 2012 il lui avait effectivement
tenu des propos sexistes puisqu'il lui
avait dit je
vais te faire atteindre des sommets
voilà alors ce qui est très intéressant
pardon c'est que la plainte en
diffamation on voit bien ce que ce que
c'est a été déposé par Éric Brion avec
la justice ne lui a pas donné raison et
ça a été tranché au plus haut niveau
c'est-à-dire au niveau de la Cour de
cassation et qui a considéré que la
balance très subtile entre la libération
de la parole des femmes la liberté
d'expression et la protection des
personnes et de leur vie privée et bien
le bal penche plutôt aujourd'hui du côté
de la liberté d'expression quitte encore
une fois à tolérer une marge d'erreur on
voit d'ailleurs que le droit en lui-même
bouge sur ces questions les partis
politiques évidemment ils ont une énorme
responsabilité comment vous juger ces
fameux cellules contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes plutôt durement ça
c'est un échec finalement elles sont
totalement inefficaces
aucune n'a réussi finalement à leur soit
elles ont pas pris on pense par exemple
à la France insoumise pour lequel des
hommes comme Eric Coquerel étaient mis
en accusation mais les cellules ne se
sont jamais saisies du cas ne serait-ce
que pour l'interroger il a fallu
attendre qu'il y ait une plainte
totalement sans objet puisqu'elle a été
classée sans suite pour que la cellule
commence à s'y intéresser alors que
toutes les personnalités du parti était
au courant de Daniel Simonnet en passant
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous revenez
aussi sur l'affaire
des personnes qui dénoncent un certain
nombre de fait vis-à-vis de ces partis
parce que
dénoncer un élu de surcroît connu
étranger le cas de cette élu au sein
même du parti forcément ça biaise et
puis il y a des cours en politique donc
ça dysfonctionne complètement et le
modèle reste à construire et on sait que
les parties réfléchissent aujourd'hui à
mettre en place des organismes
indépendants extérieurs aux parties
lui-même mais ça coûte cher voilà faire
appel à des organismes privés
en la matière Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour
terminer n'apparaît pas non plus comme
le premier des féministes on comprend
pourquoi à faire catenens on a beau
créer
sur son passé il vient pas d'une
organisation qui était particulièrement
féministe mais en 2017 2022 il a été
reconnu il a il avait le programme le
plus féministe et c'est pour ça que
l'effet boomerang était terrible pour
lui puisque finalement il a attiré dans
son parti
toutes ces jeunes femmes beaucoup de ces
jeunes en tout cas collectifs et elles
ne lui pardonne pas aujourd'hui d'avoir
à chaque fois pris la défense un mot sur
Emmanuel Macron pour pour terminer lui
non plus mais pas forcément pour des
raisons différentes on attendait
beaucoup de la grande cause du
quinquennat vous le classez pas parmi
tout il a il a raté il a raté la marche
il a soutenu on l'a vu des ministres mis
en cause pour des affaires graves et on
a encore vu récemment ça n'est que sous
la pression justement de ces collectifs
que il a fini par céder donc il est un
peu il est dans la vieille école si je
puis dire très légaliste c'est
judiciaire ou pas judiciaire et tant
qu'il y a pas une condamnation ou
quelque chose d'avérer sur le plan
judiciaire je ne sais pas tribunal
public
n'est pas encore son curseur à lui merci
beaucoup c'est passionnant on revient
dans le détail sur toutes ces affaires
ces nuancées et c'est aussi une forme
voilà il y a la point d'interrogation
devrait questionnements que chacun
d'entre nous doit avoir y compris ici
même au cœur de l'Assemblée nationale
vous restez avec nous c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris de vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
de France Info Jean-Rémy Baudot deux
France Info les deux font la paire la
politique l'économie ce soir bienvenue à
vous installez-vous on commence comme
chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir par Elsa mon Agava
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vous raconte une
histoire qui aujourd'hui elle s'est
passé comme prévu on connaît toujours
pas la fin mais on commence à avoir
quand même des scénarios dessinés je
vous parle évidemment de la proposition
de loi liotte pour abroger la réforme
des retraites nouvel épisode donc
aujourd'hui ce matin les journalistes
étaient conviés pour connaître la
décision du président de la commission
des finances
Eric Coquerel devait se prononcer sur la
recevabilité financière du texte je
pense que dans l'histoire récente des
décisions c'est celle où il y avait
vraiment le moins de suspense au bout de
20 minutes d'explications de
justification juridique sur la
jurisprudence et bien ricoquerel a donc
dit ce qu'il avait déjà annoncé écoutez
j'ai donc décidé de rendre recevable la
proposition loi sur labrogation de la
réforme du recul de l'âge de la retraite
à 64 ans et donc là pareil on aurait pu
prédire à l'avance les réactions de la
majorité qui a débarqué outré celle des
quatre colonnes pour dénoncer cette
décision qu'elle juge politique de la
part du déçu tu t'es insoumis
c'est un travail de SAP c'est un travail
de simple qui est fait aujourd'hui par
la nupestre contre nos institutions
malheureusement une utilisation
partisane politique du rôle pourtant
essentiel qui est celui de présent de la
commission des finances donc pour moi
c'est Éric Coquerel qui était recevable
au titre de président de la commission
des finances il devrait utiliser son
droit révocatoire voilà bon alors ça ce
sont surprise qu'est-ce qui va se passer
maintenant
pas le 8 juin dans la question que tout
le monde se pose c'est la question qui a
posé Charles de Courson vous savez c'est
lui qui porte le texte il l'a demandé
tout à l'heure lors de la séance de
questions au gouvernement
aussi ma question est toute simple
le gouvernement laissera-t-il
l'Assemblée nationale se prononçait sur
cette proposition de loi ou aura-t-il de
nouveau recours à des dispositions
visant à empêcher le vote
je vous remercie
regardez un Charles de Courson applaudit
à la gauche de l'hémicycle mais aussi à
l'extrême droite de l'hémicycle par les
députés du rassemblement national ça
évidemment la majorité n'a pas manqué de
le souligner alors le gouvernement la
redit il considère que cette loi cette
proposition loi est inconstitutionnelle
et qu'elle n'aboutirait pas demain le
texte arrive en commission des affaires
sociales on aura Charles de Courson à
votre place Marie-Christine tabbay
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors le
scénario c'est que la majorité face
adopter un amendement de suppression de
l'article 1 ça là toutes les chances d'y
parvenir les républicains ont notamment
fait un peu le ménage parmi leurs
députés qui siège en commission alors
c'est un peu technique mais en fait ça
obligerait le goupillotte à re-déposer
un amendement pour revenir en gros sur
le texte initial et là il y a un
personnage de cette histoire qui semble
un peu une histoire sans fin qui aurait
le droit de déclarer l'amendement
irrecevable en lieu et place de
l'insoumie Éric Coquerel c'est Yaël
brune Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale ce matin au micro de Thomas
Soto à la déclaré qu'elle était prête à
intervenir c'était avant la décision
d'Eric coquerets mais ça change pas
grand chose vu qu'on l'a vu on la
connaissait déjà
il ne doit pas y avoir de débat sur cet
article qui est clairement
anticonstitutionnel ne prend pas ses
responsabilités est-ce que vous en
présence de l'Assemblée vous prendrez
les vôtres bien sûr donc il n'y aura pas
de vote nous verrons mais en tout cas je
prendrai mes responsabilités c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et c'est ce
qu'attend de moi mes collègues et
surtout les Français il y a une pivelle
semblait la semaine dernière vouloir
plutôt se tenir à l'écart là les
oppositions on voit il voit un coup de
pression de l'exécutif sur la présidente
de l'Assemblée donc ça c'est le scénario
qui tient la corde mais on va le voir vu
que tous les plans de bataille sont déjà
dévoiler les adversaires ils cherchent
évidemment à trouver une parade on va
suivre ça évidemment de très très près
le coût politique d'être voilà mise en
minorité sera-t-il plus fort ou moins
fort qu'empêcher un vote c'est toutes
nos dilemme la politique toujours
j'aurais mis informations du brief de
France info je le précise le
rassemblement national lance un groupe
de travail sur le logement un groupe de
travail qui s'est réuni pour la première
fois aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de se
mettre à jour de trouver de nouvelles
propositions de nouvelles doctrines sur
la question spécifique du logement 2
députés RN sont à la manœuvre ils ont
tous les deux travaillé dans le secteur
Frédéric Falcon et Thomas ménager des
spécialistes donc il se rendent bien
compte que le programme actuel du RN ne
répond pas du tout à la crise du moment
alors que propose le RN aujourd'hui sur
le logement pour faire simple on trouve
favoriser l'accession à la propriété et
promouvoir la priorité nationale pour
les logements sociaux évidemment ça
n'est pas avec ça que vous gérez la
chute des constructions encore la hausse
des taux qui grippe le marché du neuf
comme de l'ancien sur le logement on est
un peu faible on est comme les autres
parties on n'a pas encore trouvé le bon
équilibre voilà ce que me disait un
proche de Marine Le Pen alors ce groupe
de travail affirme vouloir tout regarder
fiscalité artificialisation des sols
écologie rénovation avec tout ça ils
sont en chargés de faire une série de
propositions et preuve que la question
du logement est au cœur des
préoccupations actuelles du du côté du
parti d'extrême droite le député RN
Sébastien Chenu a aussi invité
Jean-Louis Borloo à intervenir cette
semaine dans son groupe d'études
transpartisans la maison son groupe
d'études territoire en reconversion on
verra si les ras ou pas Jean-Louis Borlo
le logement c'est le seul sujet de la
remise à jour du RN non et c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est que plusieurs
députés RN m'ont parlé de la nécessité
de remettre à jour le programme du RN
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat bien
que Marine Le Pen soit clairement
identifié sur le sujet dans l'opinion
c'est propositions ne sont pas reprises
il faut bien avoir en tête que l'actuel
programme du RN en fait il date de la
présidentielle donc en fait il a il
commence à dater un peu il a deux ans
quand certaines propositions ne datent
pas en réalité des mêmes des campagnes
précédentes entre temps il y a quand
même eu la crise en Ukraine la crise de
l'inflation prenez par exemple l'idée de
la TVA à 0% rabâché par le RN elle reste
discutée elle n'est reprise par aucune
force politique ni aucun économiste
sérieux ce constat qu'une mise à jour
est nécessaire c'est aussi le constat
qu'une remise à niveau est nécessaire
non on ne règle pas l'inflation avec une
TVA à 0%, non on ne résout pas la crise
du logement en distribuant des au jeune
couple on a un paradoxe le RN n'est pas
reconnu pour la puissance de son
programme économique et pourtant dans
les sondages Marine Le Pen et quasiment
la première dans les études d'opinion
sur la capacité à réformer le pays elle
surf sur ces images n'ayant pour
l'instant pas approuvé que ces solutions
sont réellement fonctionnent réellement
mais on le voit en coulisse ses équipes
veulent muscler un peu le jeu une mise à
jour peut-être au cas où je vois ça
c'est incroyable même la crédibilité
aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen arrive en tête
la compétence aussi la capacité à
réformer les temps changent non vous
voulez réagir ça vous étonne ou pas
que Marine Le Pen n'est pas identifié en
revanche sur le terrain du féminisme
c'est peut-être sur
une vous pensez qu'un jour ce sera
possible d'avoir un meeto au sein même
du RN il y en a il y en a eu il y en a
eu au Conseil
alors non elle elle ne parle pas mais en
tout cas il y a eu des affaires MiTo à
l'intérieur du Front national
qui ont concerné d'ailleurs des agressés
femmes et des agressés hommes mais c'est
vrai que Marine Le Pen on lui crédite
pas parce que finalement c'est une femme
qui réussit et on ne lui crédit pas le
fait d'être une femme en fait c'est ce
dont elle souffre un peu nous attend
expliqué dans son parti en tout cas si
elle était lu ce sera la première mais
il y a encore pas mal d'obstacles à
franchir on va terminer avec vous Fanny
cocorico est-ce qu'on peut dire allez
fierté nationale une gigafactory
l'Airbus des batteries électriques dans
le Pas-de-Calais c'est chez nous
inauguré en grande pompe aujourd'hui oui
alors cocorico c'est au niveau européen
parce que c'est vrai que 7 giga Factory
qui va faire donc des batteries pour les
véhicules électriques elle rassemble la
France l'Allemagne et l'Italie c'est une
entreprise derrière a cessé qui réunit à
la fois totale stellantis Mercedes
si c'est une immense usine qui va donc
être capable de fournir 2 millions et
demi de voitures électriques chaque
année à la fin de la décennie alors oui
cocorico parce que ce projet il a été
rapide trois ans ce qui est quand même
assez rare dans un pays qui est tout le
temps taxé d'être ralenti par des normes
dérèglementations l'État les
gouvernements ont mis un milliard et
demi de subventions avec l'Allemagne et
l'Italie pas que nous mais quand même
c'est allé très vite et on peut saluer
la prouesse parce qu'on est parti de
très très loin il y a pas si longtemps
la France était quand même au niveau
zéro et ça n'est pas terminé trois
autres usines vont sortir de terre
toujours dans le Pas-de-Calais très
rapidement bref la France veut mettre le
paquet pour construire une véritable
filière des batteries électriques alors
le problème c'est qu'on reste dépendant
des matières premières et oui alors on
essaye d'être moins dépendant de la
Chine par les batteries pour les
batteries électriques mais c'est vrai
pour les construire parce que la plupart
se font là-bas mais c'est vrai que tous
ces métaux qui viennent dans ces
batteries et bien ils viennent aussi
d'Asie ou encore là on reste dépendant
même si petit bémol on essaye là aussi
de faire un petit pas la société Imerys
par exemple a annoncé son intention
d'exploiter la première mine de lithium
dans la liée c'est en France voilà
souveraineté énergétique enfin des
terres rares des matières premières
alors est-ce qu'on est les seuls sur ce
créneau là et bien c'est le souci c'est
que on a bien démarré c'est bien voilà
on a fait un vrai pas de géant mais
c'est quand même un véritable marathon
et que toutes les tous les Européens se
battent aujourd'hui pour créer ces gigas
Factory parce que on le rappelle à
partir de 2035 il ne sera plus possible
de vendre des voitures thermiques en
Europe et puis il faut derrière que les
consommateurs puissent basculer acheter
ces véhicules 40% du prix de d'une
voiture électrique c'est ça vient de la
batterie et ces voitures électriques
elles restent encore beaucoup plus cher
que les autres alors là aussi la France
veut doper la demande aidait les
consommateurs notamment les plus
modestes à faire la bascule Emmanuel
Macron a promis une voiture un leasing
100 euros mais là aussi c'est une
promesse qui a du mal à se concrétiser
bon je vous sens un peu sceptique non
c'est bien hein quand même on voit qu'il
y a un élan
l'Airbus des batteries électriques merci
beaucoup pas de réaction ça vous inspire
non les batteries électriques le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais dans le nord de la
France évidemment que ça fait de gros
débats locaux parce que c'est ça
consomme beaucoup d'eau
de l'ouverture quel que soit l'usine
l'entrepôt en France c'est que derrière
il y a des injonctions contradictoires
on fait des emplois mais de l'autre côté
ça n'est jamais neutre évidemment bon en
tout cas c'est déjà bien en tout cas
pour nos batteries électriques chez nous
c'est que diabolikus je remonte le titre
la couverture de votre livre La revanche
des femmes avec ce point d'interrogation
nous l'avait largement expliqué pourquoi
vous l'avez mis c'est chez Albin Michel
merci Marie-Christine ta bet merci
Christophe Dubois les affranchis à très
vite je crois qu'on se voit demain ils
avaient un GABA très belle soirée sur
LCP et à demain donc Manu malheur
[Musique]